hi I'm Trixie Mattel and I'm going
undercover on the internet and this is
actually me don't ever speak to me or my
daughter again Twitter I'll do ladies
Emily B Durham that name she seems like
she's in financials how do drag queens
do their taxes the same way we do our
hair and costumes we hire people I'm
meeting my love Trixie Mattel in August
but I have no idea how to approach her
because usually going for the hugs but I
know she's got a hugger thank you so
much for acknowledging that because now
that I've come out as an on hugger
now people walk up to me and say I know
you're not a hugger but can I have a hug
I love a handshake a little high five
and I love money
honestly just walk up to me just make it
rain Rachel at Rachael food cart says
we're drag queens bites yeah shoes
asking for a friend with size 11 feet
you know Rachel
it's not super hard to find it well you
would be able to find bigger shoes that
places like pay less but I believe they
went away now you're a man shopping for
women's shoes you want a size up to
sizes so like me I'm at 12 so I buy for
teens just so you know two retweets
Rachel you need to hire a social media
person I'm just saying at Sydney's no
question for you would you ever make a
Trixie Mattel video game such as a
guitar hero with an autoharp in it I
hope you don't work in marketing yes and
nobody would buy that nobody's an
autoharp hero cuz you play guitar hero
you're playing like The Strokes I'm like
ac/dc girl ain't nobody stay in the
living room with a plastic harp like
[Music]
Trixie Mattel performs live at RuPaul's
Drag Con 2018 does anyone know what
pedal or voice box she's using to make
the harmonies that [ __ ] was led Thank
You Connor white let me get up in this
picture I love in his picture as him in
bed yeah I have a youtube but you could
also [ __ ] me this is TC Helicon voice
live acoustic it's incredible for
somebody like me who travels alone I can
create 1 2 3 4 5 voice harmonies
around my songs and I can play loops so
I can like Ed Sheeran it and play loop
songs very easy and it makes audiences
think you are a magician I can see the
audience like looking around because
they can't believe Quora
what's the dirt atutor crossdresser in a
drag queen I think that a crossdresser
is technically any one gender dressed as
another gender like as far as
cross-dressing goes I'm like the person
at karaoke who brings their own CD like
it's gone too far
cross-dressing is like your dad locking
himself in the bathroom wearing lingerie
because he thought that the whole family
left I used to do makeup for this guy
and he had a wife and kids and once a
month he used to come to my house I
would pour my glass of merlot and I
would put him in full drag and he would
go out on the town in drag doing god
knows what the end of the night he would
come back to my house and get out of
drag and go home like none of it
happened and then one day he I was doing
his makeup and he looked up at me and he
went I'm so young so lucky you can live
your whole life as you are and I was
just like heartbroken anyway do you
think Trixie Mattel should have won all
stars 3 I might be biased but she seems
like a pretty cool chick
let me tell you losing drag race choice
is quite different than winning much
more fun it was like watching Moulin
Rouge but no one died what should you
expect to see at a Trixie Mattel drag
show would it be appropriate for 15 year
old I would say it's appropriate for 15
year old um if their family's a little
dicey you know like my mom let me watch
showgirls I think when I was six
that's what kind of family I came from I
think I even saw Pulp Fiction in the
movie theaters when I was a kid so
whatever Wikipedia oh mama it's actually
me Fergus was born in first of all who's
that I'm Trixie Mattel fur kiss was born
in Milwaukee Wisconsin whoa he's half
Ojibwa and comes from a Native American
family living in crevices
who wrote the school spends their free
time researching where I came from I
love Michelle Branch I'm not up on
Wikipedia like her favorite popsicles
Orange I mean this is all accurate in
September 2018 interviewed nope
in a September 2018 nope in a in a
September 2018 interview with billboard
she announced that she's working in our
third studio album she says the album
will have an electro book sound that is
true my newest album sounds a little
more like a 90s 60s redux
so it sounds like a post Beatles Fuzzy's
plugged in Handclap II very like that
thing you do meets meets Fountains of
Wayne it's healthy cute
reddit oh my god hold on let me get my
glasses wait which ones were actually
done by Trixie I think all except for
Fifi Sharon and Katia right first of all
this looks like a clown [ __ ] dream
I'll tell you which ones I did do um I
did do Bob the drag queen looks sock
puppet let's be real I did you James say
James
that's a Jeffrey star in the lower left
corner I did do Willem and I did do
Tyler Oakley I did not do Katya I did
not do Monet exchange or Fifi O'Hara or
sharing I will say of all these I do
think Sharon's it's probably the best
she FaceTime he dressed as me holding a
butcher knife which was a very like
almost like a Black Swan experience look
at mo navel like a deep skin Trixie is
kind of very compelling it looks really
good
even more Twitter God how do dragons
hide their brows so well it's [ __ ]
hard to cover them honestly it looks
like she is a female presenting person I
was a woman doing drag or just shave
them off because if you have no eyebrows
as a woman nobody cares use drama with
my pale white skin and my note here I
need eyebrows to let people know like I
am still alive you don't need to put a
mirror to my nose I'm cool most of us
used purple disappearing glue stick from
Elmer's glue its skin safe although it's
a little bit drying just seeing them how
much eyeliner districts MIT he'll go
through in a year you would be amazed a
lot most of the time I use NYX black
cream liner it's my favorite six five
bucks and I'm gonna do it pretty fast
like I think when I won drag race
anasazi over the hills who's supposed to
give me like a year supply I was
probably like Tarrant
how long does it take to summit I'll to
do her makeup for a gig I'm baby curious
it surprises people it only takes about
an hour but at this point I look the
same every day so it's more like color
blocking like it's a process really fast
yesterday I watched clueless why I got
ready at spec 'let hmmm what does one
wear to drag go drag queen bingo
who is calling it drag oh I say at a
drag show
let the drag can be the drag queen and
let the person be the person
wear t-shirt I think one of the best
things you can wear is a piece of drag
queen merchandise if you're not sure
where attendee brown shirt here's what
not to wear to a drag show
when we step on stage and we see like a
group of bachelorettes in party pages
like Party City Bob's I want to bring
the building down I don't want to keep
to melt that wig your head posted more
aura what should you never say to a drag
queen we hate when women are like God
your boobs they're bigger than mine yeah
they look great I look great Wow your
hair is even better than mine
yeah your hair's not great wow you
didn't make it better than me yeah you
look awful
I'm a drag queen you're a person I'm
supposed to look marginally better than
you that's at the point I love to be
recognized by a fan but I don't like to
be a straight person to token like this
is a holiday are now not Mickey Mouse if
I'm at the Sheraton Hotel in the lobby
waiting for my uber Excel when you're
like a picture no drag queens
learning new things how can I learn to
be a drag queen honestly do not go down
that road unless you have something
truly special to offer it's kinda like
porn like once you've done it it's
really hard to bag that's why so many
point actors when they when they quit
porn they do drag because it's like well
what's below horn
hello where do drag queens shop we all
sort of have our schemes like most of my
costumes are custom but I love vintage
all drag queens love vintage shopping or
like go to the hood to the beauty supply
stores where you can get like skankiest
cheapest like club where like club
dresses tights leggings but most queens
at this point I think just to Amazon
I mean kicked out of so many stores in
drag I don't think that a thrift store
once in Milwaukee and dry because they
said I was dressed inappropriately oh
yeah try me Victoria's annoyed done well
that's it I answer some questions I
corrected some people and the internet
will never be the same
by that got no like Sydney take the hint